[Musique]
je suis docteur joseph sylvain j'ai
toujours haïti dans mon coeur jamais
oublié mais mes racines se trouvent à
shawinigan grammaire lao she pratique
depuis plus de 26 ans
ou échangeables tout est prêt pour
aujourd'hui dès mon enfance j'ai
toujours pensé à mes prochains c'est
comme ça que j'ai été éduqué et on a
fondé un organisme qui s'appelle action
québec plateau central
toujours dans le but de venir en aide
aux jeunes défavorisés des d'haïti on a
commencé d'abord par une bibliothèque de
ma ville natale qui savait inchy il est
concerné vous ça va au triceps
l'éducation pour moi ça vaut beaucoup
mon père a toujours dit il faut aider
les gens à pêcher au lieu de leur donner
un poisson
on a fait des missions humanitaires en
haïti à plusieurs reprises et on a été
aidé et assisté par plusieurs organise
aussi
[Musique]
après les résout à gand après les
tremblements de terre il ya plusieurs
enfants sont restés au félin donc pour
aider ces enfants là nous avons pensé
construire un orphelinat écoles
j'étais au mois de février a light i on
a acheté le terrain j'ai déjà chez tech
qui travaillent sur le plan pour nous la
mairie de chamonix non nous a beaucoup
aidés on a un entrepôt dans lesquels il
y a les appareils ils étaient tous sont
des lits des matelas qui sont entreposés
avant de les envoyer en haïti
cela nous a été donnée par l'hôpital de
shawinigan et je dois cela aussi aux
infirmiers aux infirmières les
physiothérapeutes qui est à goûter la
pique qui m'appellent souvent docteur on
a quelque chose dans la tête
et puis email ils me les ont données et
puis moi je trouve des gens vont aller
les chercher
j'ai beaucoup des policiers aussi qui
qui qui épousent cette cause l'argent
des riches y relier des policiers de
nicolet qui ne connaissent même pas
qu'ils m'envoient des chèques
on envoie des dons
[Musique]
avant d'envoyer un container je dois
être m'assurer qu'ils et tout va se
dérouler bien c'est parce que j'ai perdu
déjà des containers des gens qui m'ont
dit d'attendre d'attendre d'attendre on
peut ouvrir regardez c'est dans le but
de me rouler dans la farine
[Musique]
de voir que les gens m'appuie c'est ce
qui m'encourage à avancer même si j'ai
peu jaloux parce que la situation
d'haïti c'est pas facile
c'était moi je reçois si je les partage
pas vous partagez
moi j'aime ça beaucoup et puis si c'est
ma vie
[Musique]